[Música]
eu com sartre filósofo existencialista
teorizou que todo ser humano nasce livre
pra ser e fazer o que quiser desde que
há conseqüências de suas escolhas não
seria tão simples assim
ele frisa que todas as nossas ações têm
uma finalidade específica cada um dos
nossos atos até ao mais ínfimo deles é
inteiramente livre mas inteiramente
provido de propósito o que cada uma que
almoçou hoje foi uma escolha com
propósito ainda que não pareça é com
essas idéias que eu recebo os meus
pacientes em consultório e certa vez eu
recebi uma mãe mulher negra que decidiu
fazer psicoterapia com o intuito de se
fortalecer emocionalmente para auxiliar
a filha em algumas situações específicas
e difíceis que ela estava enfrentando do
alto dos seus cinco anos de idade
um dia ela estava voltando da casa de
uma amiguinha com que ela sempre
brincava e ao contar como foi
ela disse à mãe não brinquei muito
porque as meninas queriam brincar de
princesa a mãe perguntou se ela não
gostava de brincar de princesa
ela diz que sim mas que as meninas
tinham dito para ela que ela não podia
brincar porque não existem princesas
pretas só princesas bonitas de pele rosa
outro dia na volta da escola mãe
percebeu que ela estava meio tristinha
ao ser indagada ela disse que achava que
a professora não gostava dela como
gostava das outras crianças
isso porque a professora sempre fazia
cafuné nos cabelos das outras meninas
mas nunca havia tocado nos cabelos dela
a mãe explicou que ela tinha dela os
cabelos crespos como os dela semelhantes
aos meus
nesses dois episódios a mãe explicou a
filha carinhosa e pacientemente que
aquelas situações eram muito ruins mas
que não eram verdadeiras
ela podia sim ser princesa e que talvez
a professora não soubesse o quanto o
cabelo dela era cheiroso macio perfeito
para o boca fumê
mas essa mãe ficou mesmo sem ação e sem
argumentos
quando ela viu a sua filhinha de óleo de
jabuticaba pele negra cabelos crespos
esfregando no corpo um produto usado
para branquear roupas
dois dias depois de ter indagado a mãe
pra que serve aquele pote cor de rosa
que ela sempre colocava na máquina de
lavar a manhã havia respondido
é pra deixar as roupas mais brancas e
limpas filha a dor da minha paciente era
por perceber que sozinha ela não seria
capaz de proteger a infância de sua
filha das limitações que a desigualdade
racial impõe
ela precisaria de ajuda sua dor era por
constatar que por suas características
físicas
aquela menininha não poderia sonhar
livremente sua infância já oferecia
obstáculos
o racismo restringe as possibilidades de
sonhar dessa criança ela pode superar
sua mãe pode ajudá lo a superar mas e
nós como podemos ajudá la
como podemos ajudar milhares de outras
crianças negras cujos sonhos nem
conhecemos mas já estão sendo colhidos
o racismo é um fenômeno construído no
exercício da liberdade de cada um de nós
ea sua eliminação é portanto um desafio
de todos nós somos todos responsáveis
é por meio das nossas escolhas como
diria sartre que nós construímos e
transformamos a nós mesmos ea sociedade
em que vivemos é o exercício da nossa
liberdade que faz com que nós nos
construímos e com que nós possamos
transformar a realidade social à qual
pertencemos sartre ainda lança uma idéia
é um exercício simples pra gente
compreender se as nossas escolhas estão
contribuindo para o bom funcionamento da
sociedade ou não se as nossas escolhas
estão sendo éticas ou não
ele diz se você quer saber se a sua
escolha ética
pergunte-se como ficaria a humanidade
caso todas as pessoas do mundo
resolvessem fazer a mesma escolha que
você a humanidade ficaria melhor ou pior
as escolhas que vocês têm feito em
relação à realidade do racismo tem sido
éticas tem sido no sentido de combatê-lo
suas escolhas contribuem para não
colocar limites aos sonhos de uma
criança ou de um adulto negro precisam
sair dos antagonismos que transformam a
realidade social e meras riscos de
torcida de futebol quase vila flamengo e
fluminense corinthians e palmeiras causa
e efeito vítima e opressor brancos e
negros racistas e anti racistas não isso
não é o campeonato brasileiro de futebol
trata-se de vidas
trata-se de fazermos uma escolha ética e
responsável
só assim conseguiremos honrar a conexão
indestrutível
eu e incontestável que existe entre
todos nós
nossas escolhas pessoais são também
escolhas para toda a humanidade
nesse momento eu lhes pergunto suas
escolhas têm sido éticas muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]